at least 78 people have drowned off the
coast of Southern Greece after a fishing
boat carrying migrants sank a large
rescue operation has been launched it
was complicated by high winds more than
a hundred people have been rescued but
dozens are still missing John ceropolis
joins me live from Athens John what are
you finding out
well apart from the 78 confirmed dead we
could now have hundreds of bodies all
missing it turns out because after
initial interviews with the survivors of
whom there are 104 we're told at this
point the boat was originally carrying
hundreds of people perhaps upwards of
500. it's not clear
what has happened to those remaining
people whether they are swimming in the
ionian sea whether they're whether
they're drowned whether more corpses are
being collected there is a search and
rescue operation going on we're told
that when the Greek Coast Guard offered
help the people on this boat initially
refused because it was their hope to
reach Italy they had set out from to
Brook in Libya and they were obviously
blown off course it's also not clear yet
from the authorities why this boat
failed why it capsized or sank what
we're hearing from the authorities here
in Greece is that the president of the
Republic
is heading down to Kalamata which is the
nearest hospital where the survivors are
being taken and that a major relief
effort is being mounted to bring these
people food and clothing that's what we
know so far it's a little more detail on
what obviously appears now to be a major
disaster with not hundreds of people but
possibly hundreds of families drowned
off the coast between Greece and Italy
and John this is yet another tragedy in
the Mediterranean Sea Greece like other
countries whether it's Tunisia whether
it's Italy others has seen its fair
share of disasters
it has and I think if this disaster
shapes up to the way it seems that it's
going with many many more people drowned
it could even surpass the uh the the
most fatality Laden incident that the
Greek Coast Guard has so far handled
which was a capsizing of a boat offshore
Lesbos in October 2015 with more than
200 people drowned then
um as that boat left the Turkish Shores
uh it capsized because it was overloaded
with people and that could well turn out
to be the case here as well except in
this case the boat obviously reached uh
when went quite a long way further uh it
was it was found the survivors were
found 47 nautical miles west southwest
of the Greek coast of pilos in the
southwest peloponnese so it had
obviously come a long way from Libya
before it ran into trouble
um so it is something that the Greek
authorities are experienced in handling
but
I don't think that we've had another
incident in which many hundreds of
people have been drowned the the worst
one was this off uh off Lesbos in 2015.
all right John ceropoulos reporting from
Athens thank you very much look we'll
let you go in news gather and when you
find out of any significant developments
you will keep a surprise thank you John